Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. I felt quite fresh and was delighted with the enthusiastic welcome of the crowds who were waiting in the rain and who gave me the Nazi salute and shouted hail at the tops of their voices all the way to the station. There we entered Hitler's special train for the three-hour journey to Berchtesgaden. All the way up there were people at the crossings, the stations, and at the windows of the houses, all hiling and saluting. We drove to the brown house a good deal higher up the mountain. Halfway
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我感到相当清爽，并对冒雨等候在路旁的人群的热情欢迎感到高兴，他们一路上对我行纳粹礼，并声嘶力竭地高呼“万岁”，直到火车站。在那里，我们登上了希特勒的专列，开始了历时三小时前往贝希特斯加登的行程。一路上，十字路口、火车站以及房屋的窗户边都有人在高呼口号并行礼。我们驱车前往山势更高的“棕色之邸”。半途
down the steps stood the Fuhrer, bare-headed, and dressed in a khaki-colored coat of broadcloth with a red armlet and a swastika on it, and the military cross on his breast. He wore black trousers, such as we wear in the evening, and black patent-leather lace-up shoes. His hair is brown, not black. His eyes blue. His expression rather disagreeable, especially in repose, and altogether he looks entirely undistinguished. You would never notice him in a crowd, and would take him for the house painter he once was. After saying some words of welcome, he took me up the steps and introduced me to a number of people, among whom I only distinguished General Keitel, a youngish, pleasant-faced, smart-looking soldier. We then entered the house, and passed along a very bare passage to the celebrated chamber,
台阶下方站着元帅，他赤着头，身穿一件厚呢卡其色大衣，上面佩戴着红袖标和纳粹万字标志，胸前挂着军功十字勋章。他穿着黑色的裤子，就像我们在晚间穿的那种，还穿着黑色的漆皮系带皮鞋。他的头发是棕色的，不是黑色的。眼睛是蓝色的。他的表情相当令人不快，特别是在平静的时候，而且总的来说，他看起来完全平庸无奇。你在人群中绝对不会注意到他，会把他当成他曾经做过的油刷工。在说了几句欢迎的话后，他带我走上台阶，把我介绍给了一群人，其中我只认得凯特尔将军，一个年轻、面容和善、显得精明能干的军人。随后我们进入屋内，穿过一条非常简陋的走廊，来到了那个著名的房间，
or rather hall, one end of which is entirely occupied by a vast window. The view towards Salzburg must be magnificent. But this day there were only the valley and the bottoms of the mountains to be seen. That was Neville Chamberlain who was writing to his sister Ida after his trip to Hitler's mountain lair on Thursday the 15th September 1938. And Dominic seems to have been completely obsessed with what Hitler was wearing. Amazing attention to detail. But I suppose it's a novelty for Chamberlain. Hitler's shoes. Yes. Black patent leather lace up shoes. Yeah. You would never, you would take him for the house painter he once was.
或者不如说是个大厅，大厅的一端完全是一扇巨大的窗户。朝萨尔茨堡望去的景色一定壮丽非凡。但这一天，只能看到山谷和群山的山脚。那是内维尔·张伯伦在1938年9月15日星期四前往希特勒位于山上的巢穴后写给他妹妹艾达的信。多米尼克似乎对希特勒穿的衣服完全着迷了。对细节的关注真是惊人。但我想这对张伯伦来说是个新鲜事。希特勒的鞋子。是的。黑色漆皮系带鞋。是的。你绝对不会注意到他，你会把他当成他曾经做过的油刷工。
Which he wasn't, was he? No, he was never a house painter. He was a postcard painter. The fact that Chamberlain is describing it in such banal detail to his sister, this extraordinary meeting is a reminder of an unprecedented moment it is, right? People don't normally do this. So in the last episode, the first of our two part series on Munich, we talked about how rare it is for European statesmen to do this, to fly to each other's countries at the drop of a hat for an emergency summit. This didn't happen in the buildup to the First World War. Chamberlain is doing something extraordinary here. He's boarded his plane, we ended last time, a Heston aerodrome.
他以前又不是，对吧？不，他从来不是油刷工。他是个明信片画师。张伯伦以如此平淡的细节向他的妹妹描述这次非凡的会面，这提醒了我们这是一个前所未有的时刻，对吧？人们平时不会这样做。所以在上一集中，也就是我们关于慕尼黑的两集系列的第二集的第一集，我们谈到过欧洲政治家这样做是多么罕见，他们说飞就飞到彼此的国家去参加紧急峰会。在第一次世界大战爆发前并没有发生过这种情况。张伯伦在这里做了一件非凡的事。他登上了飞机，就像我们在上一集结尾时说的那样，从赫斯顿机场起飞。
He's launching this remarkable diplomatic coup in a desperate attempt to avoid war over Czechoslovakia, a war that Hitler is planning to launch on the 1st of October, which is just two weeks away. And which Chamberlain doesn't know that, of course. No, Chamberlain doesn't know that at all. So just on Chamberlain and his flight, Chamberlain left with the goodwill of the British press kind of ringing in his ears. Every newspaper in Britain said it was brilliant that Chamberlain was doing this.
他正在发起这场非凡的外交政变，这是为了极力避免因捷克斯洛伐克而爆发战争——一场希特勒计划在10月1日（也就是仅仅两周后）发动的战争。而张伯伦当然并不知道这一点。不，张伯伦对此一无所知。所以，就张伯伦和他的飞行而言，张伯伦在英国媒体几乎是一片赞誉声中出发的。英国的每一家报纸都说张伯伦这样做太棒了。
They were so excited. The news from Paris, you know, Paris sent him kind of messages of support. The French are delighted that he's doing it. Crucially, I think for Britain, the Dominions, that is Australia, Canada, and so on, New Zealand, they have made it clear to him they are very, very reluctant to be dragged into a war in Central Europe. Right, because if the British don't want to die for Czechoslovakia, I guess if you're in Wellington or Sydney, I mean, even Madder. Exactly.
他们太兴奋了。来自巴黎的消息，你知道的，巴黎向他发去了各种支持的信息。法国人对他的做法感到高兴。至关重要的是，我认为对英国来说，自治领，也就是澳大利亚、加拿大等等，新西兰，他们已经向他明确表示，他们非常非常不愿意被拖入中欧的一场战争。没错，因为如果英国人不想为捷克斯洛伐克去死，我想如果你身在惠灵顿或悉尼，我的意思是，甚至更加不愿。完全正确。
So off he goes with their goodwill. It's actually not his first flight. This is one of the things that people think about Chamberlain that is wrong. He got up with, with, um, with the future George VI, hadn't he? At some air show or something. Is that right? That's an industrial fair in Birmingham in the 1920s. That's so chaste.
于是他带着众人的善意出发了。实际上这并不是他的第一次飞行。这是人们对张伯伦的错误看法之一。他曾经和未来的乔治六世一起坐过飞机，不是吗？在某个航展上还是什么的？是这样吗？那是20世纪20年代在伯明翰的一个工业博览会上。真是单纯啊。
It is, yeah. And they'd only like gone, circled the field and then landed again, but he had been in a plane before that. It was great fun. Anyway, he's traveled this time with his closest aide, who is a guy called Sir Horace Wilson, who is one of the civil servants, who was one of the key architects of the appeasement policy. Basically, let's solve the European issue by giving into what they're more reasonable demands. That's how they see it. So they have ham sandwiches and they drink whiskey on the flight. I think that's an excellent combination actually. I think more airlines should offer that as an option.
确实，是的。他们当时只是绕着飞行场转了一圈然后就降落了，但在此之前他确实坐过飞机。那挺好玩的。不管怎样，他这次旅行带上了他最亲密的助手，一个名叫贺拉斯·威尔逊爵士的人，他是一位公务员，也是绥靖政策的主要设计师之一。基本上就是，让我们通过满足他们比较合理的诉求来解决欧洲问题。他们就是这么看的。所以在航班上他们吃火腿三明治，喝威士忌。我认为这其实是一个极好的搭配。我觉得更多的航空公司应该把它作为一个选项。
It's a smooth flight, but then they get into Munich and there's a bit of a storm, a bit of turbulence. Oh, there's an omen there. Yes. It is an Omen. Yeah. They are escorted by a German plane to the ground. Chamberlain comes out of the plane and he's very happy. He's smiling for the cameras. He's very confident. In his own mind, I think it's really important for people to get this in their heads about Munich.
这是一次平稳的飞行，但随后他们飞抵慕尼黑，遇到了一场暴风雨，有些颠簸。哦，那是个预兆。是的。这确实是个预兆。是的。他们由一架德国飞机护送着降落。张伯伦走出飞机，他非常高兴。他在镜头前微笑。他非常自信。在我的脑海里，我认为让人们牢牢记住这一点对于慕尼黑事件真的很重要。
Chamberlain is not doing all this sort of reluctantly, grudgingly, like he is the victim in all this. He's seizing the moment. In his mind, he is the star. He is the hero of the hour. He is the man of destiny, the modern politician who has seized European history by the scruff of its neck. The arbiter of the continent's fate. That's exactly how he sees himself.
张伯伦并不是那种很不情愿、勉勉强强、觉得自己好像是这一切中的受害者一样的态度。他在抓住时机。在他的心目中，他是主角。他是此地此时的英雄。他是命运之子，是那位一把揪住欧洲历史命运后颈皮的现代政治家。是这块大陆命运的仲裁者。他正是这样看待自己的话虽如此。
Although that said, the anti-appeasement MP Harold Nicholson said that Chamberlain and Horace Wilson arrived in Germany with, and I quote, the bright faithfulness of two curates entering a pub for the first time. That's a brilliant description. Which I think is pretty close to the mark. So you sort of get a sense of that from Chamberlain's from that reading, right? He gets this big sort of- It's very pooterish quality.
话虽如此，反绥靖政策的议员哈罗德·尼科尔森曾说，张伯伦和贺拉斯·威尔逊抵达德国时，我引用原话：“带着两个第一次走进酒吧的年轻牧师那种天真无邪的忠诚。”这是一个精彩的描述。我认为这相当贴切。所以你从张伯伦的那些话里多少能感受到这一点，对吧？他有这种非常迂腐的特质。
Yeah. There were lots of cars, people saluting, Hitler had some smart shoes on. He wore black trousers. So he arrives at the Berghof, Hitler's Eyrie, his eagle's nest. It's pouring with rain, it's very cloudy, which is why he says he can't see Salzburg. He's not the first British visitor to go there. David Lloyd George. And the Duke of Windsor who had been Edward VIII notoriously had been there. Exactly. And Hitler as he describes, he's waiting from the steps, they shake hands. If you look at the photos, they both look very jolly. Chamberlain of course has his
是的。有大量的汽车，人们在行礼，希特勒穿着一双时髦的鞋子。他穿着黑色的裤子。于是他抵达了贝格霍夫，希特勒的世外桃源，他的鹰巢。外面下着倾盆大雨，多云密布，这就是为什么他说看不到萨尔茨堡。他并不是第一个去那里的英国访客。大卫·劳埃德·乔治去过。温莎公爵，也就是曾因臭名昭著而退位的爱德华八世，也去过。完全正确。正如他所描述的，希特勒在台阶上等待，他们握了握手。如果你看照片，两人看起来都兴高采烈。张伯伦当然拿着他的
umbrella and his hat. He obviously makes this remark about Hitler looking like a house painter. And actually he's even more damning. I mean mean British snobbery is a great theme with these episodes. When he goes back to the cabinet later on he says Hitler wasn't a quote the commonest little dog he had ever seen, though it was impossible not to be impressed with the power of the man. So he despises Hitler and yet at the same time he recognizes that there is a kind of demonic quality to Hitler, though as we will see I think Chamberlain completely misreads the balance of power between himself and Hitler. Anyway, he's arrived at the eagle's nest. Hitler says, come into my study. They go into his study. Ribbentrop, who is hanging around, is not invited
雨伞和帽子。他显然对希特勒看起来像个油刷工发表了这一评论。实际上，他的批评甚至更严厉。我的意思是，英国人的势利是这些剧集的一个重大主题。当他后来回到内阁时，他说希特勒简直是“他见过的最粗俗的小市民”，尽管不可能不对这个男人的力量留下深刻印象。因此，他鄙视希特勒，但与此同时，他又承认希特勒身上有一种恶魔般的特质，尽管正如我们所将看到的，我认为张伯伦完全误读了自己与希特勒之间的力量对比。不管怎样，他到达了鹰巢。希特勒说，进我的书房吧。他们走进了书房。里宾特洛甫一直在周围转悠，却没有被邀请
in. So that would have improved his mood. No, no, he hates Chamberlain, hates Britain, loves German sparkling wine, but hates Britain. He's not allowed into his Red Cross. And for three hours they talk and there's the storm raging outside, very kind of vulcanarian. Hitler is speaking quite softly. It's all been translated by his interpreter, who's a guy called Paul Schmidt. And he's going on and on about how badly the Sudeten Germans are treated. And Chamberlain says, look, if you will rule out force, I will consider anything to make you happy. Now we can talk about any kind of solution, but you must not fight.
进去。所以这本该改善他的心情。不，不，他讨厌张伯伦，讨厌英国，喜欢德国起泡酒，但讨厌英国。他没有被允许进入红十字会。他们交谈了三个小时，外面狂风暴雨肆虐，非常具有某种瓦肯式的风格。希特勒说话声音很轻。这一切都由他的翻译翻译，那个人叫保罗·施密特。他喋喋不休地讲着苏台德地区的德国人受到了多么糟糕的待遇。张伯伦说，听着，如果你能排除使用武力，我会考虑任何能让你高兴的方案。现在我们可以谈论任何形式的解决办法，但你绝不能打仗。
Hitler at this point loses his temper and he says, well, I mean, you talk to me about force, he says, but Benesh and the Czechs, they're already using force against my countrymen in the Sudetenland. I will not accept this. You know, I will settle this question, all this kind of thing. And then he starts a trouble with Hitler. He can't control himself. He goes off on a rant, doesn't he? He goes on a massive rant. He says, I don't care if there's a world war. You know, if I want to settle this, I'd rather have a world war. Frankly, I'd have a less of a world war. And Chamberlain is very cross with
希特勒此时发脾气了，他说，好吧，我的意思是，你跟我谈论武力，他说，但是贝奈斯和捷克人，他们已经在苏台德地区对我的同胞使用武力了。我绝不接受这一点。你知道的，我会解决这个问题的，诸如此类的话。然后他开始和希特勒闹别扭。他无法控制自己。他开始破口大骂，不是吗？他开始疯狂大骂。他说，我才不管有没有世界大战呢。你知道的，如果我想解决这个问题，我宁愿打一场世界大战。坦白说，我宁愿打一场世界大战。而张伯伦非常生气
this point. Chamberlain does not give in to him. Chamberlain is not a wimp and a weed. Chamberlain says, well, if you think like that, then I've completely wasted my time. There's no point in coming. He says, if that's your intention, why did you have me come into Berketer's garden at all? Under these circumstances, I think it's better if I leave straight away. And amazingly, Hitler backs down at this point. People don't normally talk like this to Hitler. Hitler says, oh, well, well, let's go back to your previous thing. You said you would grant self-determination to the states and Germans. Well, maybe we could, maybe let's talk about how that would work in reality. And Chamberlain obviously thinks to himself at this point, you stand
这一点。张伯伦没有向他屈服。张伯伦不是个懦夫和软蛋。张伯伦说，好吧，如果你这么想，那我完全就是在浪费时间。根本没有来的必要。他说，如果你是这个意图，为什么还要让我来贝希特斯加登？在这种情况下，我看我还是马上离开的好。令人惊奇的是，希特勒在这个时候退缩了。人们平时不会这样跟希特勒说话。希特勒说，哦，好吧，好吧，让我们回到你之前说的话题。你刚才说你会把民族自决权给予各州和德国人。好吧，也许我们可以，也许我们可以谈谈这在现实中该如何运作。而张伯伦此时显然心里在想，你只要对这家伙态度强硬，他就会退缩，他就会变得讲理。我们是怎么知道这些的？这是来自施密特、希特勒还是张伯伦？所以这是多种来源的结合，施密特后来写了回忆录，在其中谈到了这一切。施密特是一个了不起的信息来源，但张伯伦也向他的内阁汇报了这一切，他还把这些写信告诉了他的姐姐们。就像我们开头读到的写给艾达的信那样。所以我们得到了各种不同的……因此，存在这样一种可能性，即他可能稍微夸大了他自己的……哦，我想在整个过程中，张伯伦绝对是把自己稍微吹嘘了一番。
up to this bloke and he will back down, he will be reasonable. How are we getting this? Is this from Schmidt or Hitler or from Chamberlain? So this is a combination of Schmidt wrote memoirs later on where he talked about all this. Schmidt is an amazing source, but also Chamberlain reports all this to his cabinet, and he also writes about it to his sisters. So the letter to Ida that we began with. So we get kind of different... So there is a possibility that he might be slightly bigging up his... Oh, I think throughout this Chamberlain is definitely bigging himself up a bit.
对此毫无疑问。在张伯伦版本的谈话中，他永远是主角，而且他把希特勒玩弄于股掌之间。然而我认为在现实中，情况恰好相反。不管怎样，他们达成了共识。张伯伦将返回英国并与内阁进行商议，而希特勒则表示，好的，我等你的消息，而且我不会下令采取任何仓促的军事行动。于是张伯伦离开了，他下山住在贝希特斯加登山脚下的一家酒店里。现在张伯伦觉得太棒了，我取得了很好的结果。希特勒在张伯伦走后欣喜若狂，
I don't think there's any doubts about that. In Chamberlain's version of the conversations, he is always the star and he is playing Hitler. Whereas I think in reality, it's the other way around. Anyway, they agree. Chamberlain will go back to Britain and we'll talk to his cabinet and Hitler says, fine, I'll wait for that and I won't order any precipitate military action. And so Chamberlain goes off and he goes down and stays at a hotel down at the bottom of the mountain in Berchtesgaden. Now Chamberlain thinks great, I've got a good result. Hitler, once Chamberlain has gone is delighted and
他搓着双手，字面意义上的搓着双手，他对里宾特洛甫说，好了，我让张伯伦把苏台德地区交给我了。他说这是双赢。如果捷克人拒绝且不愿顺从这一点，那么我们就会打一仗。如果他们答应了，那么我就收回苏台德地区，也许我过一会儿就会回来拿走剩下的捷克领土。他们都觉得张伯伦是个拿着雨伞的老古董，对吧？确实如此。他们都在某种程度上嘲笑他，觉得他荒谬可笑。而且希特勒不是确实做出过某种姿态，说他可能会去伦敦，但他担心自己会被英国犹太人诘问吗？
he's rubbing his hands with glee, literally rubbing his hands and he says to Ribbentrop, well, I've got Chamberlain to give me this Sudetenland. He says it's win-win. If the Czechs refuse and won't go along with this, then we'll have a war. And if they say yes, then I'll take the Sudetenland and maybe I'll just come back for the rest of the Czechs to back here later. And they all think that Chamberlain is a fuddy-duddy old bloke with an umbrella, don't they? They do. They're all kind of laughing at him and thinking he's ridiculous. And doesn't, Hitler does kind of make an offer, say that he might go to London, but he's worried that he will be heckled by British Jews.
他自以为会受到不好的对待。完全正确。所以他从来没去过。那从未发生过。不，为了英国的形象着想，我们从来没有把希特勒请过来，这大概可能是最好的结果了。他去过利物浦，不是吗？是的。所以关于希特勒这里的提议，对吧，就是它与他以前想要的东西有相当大的出入。在此之前，他一直把苏台德地区仅仅作为夺取整个捷克斯洛伐克的借口。
He'll be poorly treated in his own mind. Exactly. So he never does. That never happens. No, I think probably best for British, for Britain's image that we never had Hitler over. He went to Liverpool, didn't he? Yeah. So the thing about Hitler's offer here, right, is that it is quite a departure from what he previously wanted. Up to this point, he's been talking about the Sudetenland merely as a pretext to get the whole of Czechoslovakia.
他不仅仅想要苏台德地区，他想要瓜分整个捷克斯洛伐克。但现在他说，好吧，也许我只会拿走苏台德地区，以后再回来拿走剩下的捷克斯洛伐克。从这个程度来看，他算是在某种程度上退让了。不管怎样，张伯伦回到伦敦，每个人都说，哦，你做得太棒了。干得好。你真是个了不起的人。他径直进去向内阁作简报。在这里，我常常觉得人们很容易对张伯伦进行毫不留情的敌视。但在这里，我认为很难不对他抱有敌意，因为他显然完全误读了局势，因为他说，我见过希特勒，我绝对
He doesn't just want the Sudetenland, he wants to break up the whole of Czechoslovakia. But now he's saying, well, maybe I will just take the sedation land and I'll come back for Czechoslovakia for the rest later. So to that extent, he has kind of slightly blinked. Anyway, Chamberlain goes back to London, everyone says, oh, you've done brilliantly. Well done. What a tremendous man you are. And he goes straight in to brief the cabinet. And here I think it's sometimes tempting to just be unremittingly hostile to Chamberlain. But here is a point where I think it's very difficult to be anything but hostile because he clearly has completely misread the situation because he says, I've met Hitler, I'm absolutely
坚信希特勒的目标是严格受限的。他说，我相信希特勒所说的话，他只想把说德语的人接纳进来。就像乔治·布什凝视弗拉基米尔·普京的眼睛一样。是的。看到一个好人。这正是他所说的。他说，好吧，尽管我在他脸上看到了严厉和冷酷，但我得到的印象是，这是一个一旦许下诺言就值得信赖的人。我的意思是，鉴于我们所了解的
convinced that Hitler's objectives are strictly limited. He says, I believe Hitler when he says he only wants to bring German speakers in. Like George Bush gazing into Vladimir Putin's eyes. Yeah. Seeing a good man. This is exactly what he says. He says, well, in spite of the harshness and ruthlessness I thought I saw in his face, I got the impression that here was a man who could be relied upon when he had given his word. I mean, given what we know
关于希特勒的一切，所以他们知道国会纵火案和长刀之夜，他们知道德奥合并，他们知道所有这些。张伯伦说出这样的话太疯狂了。是的。好吧，还有一件事是，此时的捷克人又该怎么办呢？因为他们没有出席这次决定他们国家命运的会议。所以再次说明，我查阅了一下资料，捷克人因此以非常可以理解的、极其恶劣的言辞来形容所有参与其中的人。所以他们把贺拉斯·威尔逊描述为一头母猪。他们把法国外交部长称为猪。所以有许多类似猪的意象。他们，他们，他们，他们把法国外交部长称为猪。所以有许多类似猪的意象。他们把张伯伦称为老头子。其中一个人写道，张伯伦政府对待我们国家元首的方式，就好像他是一个统治着
about Hitler, so they know about the lights and the long knives, they know about the Anschluss, they know all this. That's a mad thing for Chamberlain to say. Yeah. Well, also the other thing is what about the Czechs at this point? Because they're not present at this meeting, which is deciding the fate of their country. So again, I kind of looked this up and checks, so leading checks are describing everyone involved in this in kind of very understandably, very abusive terms. So they described the Horace Wilson as a sow. They referred to the French foreign minister as the swine. So there's a lot of kind of poor sign based imagery. They, they, they, they referred to Chamber French foreign minister as the swine. So there's a lot of kind of porcine based imagery. They refer to Chamberlain as the old man. And one of them writes, the Chamberlain government is treating our head of state as if he were N word chieftain ruling
某个麻烦不断的殖民部落的未开化酋长一样。是的，捷克人，他们感到无比愤怒。他们是对的。我的意思是，纳粹显然在以一种非常殖民主义的方式行事，但英国人也是如此。这有点像是，你知道的，让我们在这里地图上画一条线，管他呢。是的。我的意思是，你可以这么说。如果你是一个捷克人，听这个播客，你会觉得，英国人这里的表现完全是傲慢自大。这基本上就是把我们一半的国家给出卖了。我的意思是，这就是慕尼黑的故事，不是吗？捷克人，接下来几天的故事其实非常简单。在法国极其热情的支持下，英国人对捷克人说，
some troublesome colonial tribe. Yeah, the Czechs, they feel absolutely furious. And they're right. I mean, the Nazis are obviously behaving in a very colonial manner, but the British are as well. It's kind of like, you know, let's draw a line on the map here and whatever. Yeah. I mean, you could say exactly. If you're a Czech, listen to this podcast, you're like, the British are behaving with complete arrogance here. That's basically signing half our country away. I mean, that's the story of Munich, isn't it? The Czechs, the story of the next few days is actually really simple. The British with very enthusiastic French backing say to the Czechs,
好了，你们必须把苏台德地区交出去。而且不，你们可能甚至都不应该组织全民公投。直接交出来就行了。这是最快的做法。所以我的问题是，捷克人难道就不能继续战斗吗？他们拥有这一切工业腹地。他们拥有武器。
right, you've got to give them the Sudetenland. And no, you probably shouldn't even organize a referendum. Just hand it over. That's the quickest thing to do. So here's my question. Couldn't the Czechs have fought on anyway? They've got all this industrial hinterland. They've got arms.
他们在群山之中拥有这道不可思议的马奇诺防线。非常、非常令人印象深刻，如果他们把苏台德地区交出去，他们就会失去这道防线，因为它就位于苏台德地区的侧翼。他们为什么不直接开战呢？特别是考虑到此时德国经济正处于崩溃的边缘。因为，首先，他们对德国经济的情况一无所知，但同样，他们也会输。德国人已经进行了他们的军事演习。他们相当自信能在几周内获胜。
They've got this incredible Maginot line in the mountains. Very, very impressive, which they will lose if they hand over the Sudetenland, because it's on the flank of the Sudetenland. Why don't they just fight? Particularly because the German economy is on the point of collapse at this point. Because, well, first of all, they don't know that about the German economy, but also they will lose. The Germans have done their war games. They're pretty confident they can win in a matter of weeks.
但无论如何他们都要输的。我想他们认为自己正承受着来自所谓的“朋友”的巨大压力。讲点理吧。把苏台德地区让给他们。反正那里到处都是说德语的人。但关键是，凭借那些防御工事，他们本可能会有一线生机。如果他们放弃了这些防御工事，他们就真的一点机会都没有了。我的意思是，他们，你知道的，你说得完全对。你说得完全对。这个播客的很多听众无疑会说你们是对的。我想这是因为他们觉得，既然无论如何都会输，也许如果我们能得到国际担保，我们把苏台德地区交出去，然后我们就能得到法国和英国的保证。
But they're going to lose anyway. I guess they think they're being put under enormous pressure by their supposed friends. Be reasonable. Give them the Sudetenland. It's full of German speakers anyway. But the thing is with those defences, they would have had perhaps a chance. If they surrender those defences, they haven't got any chance at all. I mean, they're, you know, you're quite right. You're quite right. And lots of listeners to this podcast will no doubt say you were right. I think it's because they think, given that we'll lose either way, maybe if we get an international guarantee, we give them the Sudetenland and then we get a guarantee by the French and the British.
我的意思是，你把这与俄罗斯和乌克兰进行了比较。我的意思是，西方所有人都以为乌克兰会在俄罗斯越过边境的那一刻就战败。在我看来，捷克人当时的处境似乎比乌克兰人还要强大。是的，而且捷克人可以说比一年后的波兰人处境还要好。确实如此。波兰，大约一个月就被占领了。捷克人能坚守两个月或更长时间吗？我的意思是，最终，我认为德国人还是会赢。而且捷克人孤立无援？
I mean, you've made comparisons with Russia and Ukraine. I mean, everyone in the West assumed that Ukraine would lose the moment the Russians crossed the border. The Czech seem in a stronger position to me than the Ukrainians. Yeah, and the Czechs are arguably in a stronger position than the Poles were a year later. For sure. Poland, that took about a month. Could the Czechs have held out for two months or longer? I mean, ultimately, I think the Germans would have won. And the Czechs with no allies?
这要求太高了。我想也是。而且他们周围还有匈牙利人和波兰人虎视眈眈，不是吗？哦，是的。你的邻居们也对你有点想法。不过我只是在想，我的意思是，这场悲剧在于，他们的防御非常、非常令人印象深刻。是的。他们不得不放弃这一切。
That's a big ask. I suppose. And they've got the Hungarians and the Poles sniffing around as well, haven't they? Oh yeah. Your neighbors fancy a bit of you as well. I just wonder though, I mean, the tragedy of this is that they, they are very, very impressively defended. Yeah. They have to give all that up.
是的，当然。当然，当然，当然。因为发生的事情是，基本上在几天之内，在英国和法国无情的压力下，他们屈服了。9月21日，他们收到了来自布拉格的消息，捷克斯洛伐克政府悲痛地接受了法英两国的提议，但他们提出了条件，即你们将竭尽全力维护我们的核心利益，也就是说苏台德地区将被割让，但你们或许会给我们一个保证，或者给我们一个承诺，或者无论如何给我们点什么。是的，这显然连写它的纸张都不值。嗯，就是这样，不是吗？与此同时，希特勒在这一切期间一直在做什么呢？
Yeah, of course. Of course, of course. Because what happens is that basically after a few days, they give him under unrelenting French and British pressure. On the 21st of September, they get a message from Prague, the Czechoslovak government sadly accepts the French and British proposals, but they say that on the condition that you will do everything to safeguard our vital interests, i.e. the Sudetenland will be given away, but you will maybe give us a guarantee or give us a pledge or give us something anyway. Yeah, which would obviously not be worth the paper it's written on. Well, that's the thing, isn't it? So meanwhile, what's Hitler been doing during all this?
他一直在做他一贯的事情，当他感到压力大且有很多大发脾气的时候，他就会看那些糟糕的电影。修理旗杆上的洞。完全正确。做所有诸如此类的事情。他认为捷克人可能不会给他想要的东西，但他现在见过张伯伦后，他想，嘿，这家伙是不会打仗的。这家伙永远不会去打仗。所以他对戈培尔说，我想我们现在大概可以再多争取一点。我觉得，我觉得让我们把筹码加高点。所以让我们来到9月22日。现在我们欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。
He has been doing his usual thing, which he does when he's stressed and he has massive lions, watches these terrible films. Works at holes in flag poles. Exactly. Does all this kind of thing. He thinks that the Czechs probably won't give him what he wants, but he now having seen Chamberlain, he thinks, hey, that guy's not going to fight. That guy's never going to go to war. So he says to Goebbels, I think we can probably push for a bit more actually. I think, I think let's think let's up the ante. So let's get to the 22nd of September. Now we welcome back to the rest of this history.
是的。我们所有关于两次世界大战之间的德国的系列节目的一个重大主题，那就是温泉酒店主题。所以大家会记得我们在上一季有很多温泉酒店。特别是长刀之夜，对吧？那基本上几乎全部都是以温泉为基地的。婚礼和温泉。嗯，这就像是一个粉丝最喜欢的地点。我们正在重访长刀之夜的
Yeah. A great theme of all our series about Germany between the wars, which is the spa hotel theme. So people will remember we had a lot of spa hotels in the last season. Particularly the Night of the Long Knives, wasn't it? Which was all based in spas pretty much. Weddings and spas. Well, it's like a fan favourite location. We're revisiting one of the Night of the Long Knives
温泉酒店之一，因为张伯伦和丘吉尔之间的下一次会面定在莱茵河畔巴特戈德斯贝格的一家温泉酒店，靠近波恩。所以，弥漫着硫磺的气味。是的。是的。大量流着汗的德国人用桦树枝互相抽打或者他们做的那种事。一杯杯的热水。是的。喝着像肮脏的水一样的东西。就像在没来由地大笑。简直太可怕了。无论如何，张伯伦在正午过后不久降落在科隆机场。按照传统，他带着他的雨伞。他不得不检阅一支党卫军部队，然后被车送到莱茵河右岸的这家酒店，彼得斯堡酒店。里宾特洛甫为他进行了装修，
spa hotels because the next meeting between Chamberlain and Churchill is scheduled for a spa hotel in Bad Gordersberg on the Rhine River near Bonn. So, a fume of sulfur. Yeah. Yeah. Enormous sweating Germans beating each other with birch twigs or whatever they do. Mugs of hot water. Yeah. Drinking like filthy water. Like laughing at nothing. Just dreadful. Anyway, Chamberlain lands at Cologne Airport just after midday. He's got his umbrella as is traditional. He has to inspect a detachment of SS troops, then he's driven to this hotel on the right bank of the Rhine, the Petersberg Hotel. It's been decorated for him by Ribbentrop,
我看到里面塞满了水果、雪茄、绣球花和古龙水。真够庸俗的。所以，是的，完全如此。你一到那儿，就有一堆古龙水。真够俗气的。尼基·哈斯姆一定会讨厌这个。希特勒在莱茵河的对岸，一个粉丝最喜欢的地点，德累斯顿酒店。这里是他曾计划谋杀恩斯特·罗姆的地方。所以对他来说都是美好的回忆。但他当时的状态糟糕透顶，汤姆。
who stuffed it, I read, with fruit, cigars, hydrangeas and eau de cologne. So common. So, yeah, exactly. You turn up and there's a load of eau de cologne. That's common. Nikki Haslam would hate that. Hitler was on the other bank of the Rhine, a fan favourite, the Dresden Hotel. This was where he had planned the murder of Ernst Röhm. So happy memories for him. But he's in terrible form, Tom.
他紧张兮兮的。张伯伦要来了。记者们，记者们都在那里，那个地方挤满了媒体，他们看到他神情紧绷，不停抽搐。正是在这个时候，他们开始传播一个谣言，一些媒体——其实是德国媒体——说他吃地毯。所以他们给他起了个绰号叫 Teppich-Fresser，意思是“咬地毯的人”。这成为了20世纪30年代、40年代媒体中希特勒的一个大绰号，人们会说，“哦，希特勒，他总是咬
He's all nervous. Chamberlain's coming. The journalists, journalists are there, the place is swarming the press and they see him looking strained and twitching. And it's at this point that they start a rumor, some of the press, the German press actually, that he choose the carpets. So they nickname him the Teppich-Fresser, which means the carpet biter. And this becomes a big nickname for Hitler in the kind of 1930s, 1940s among the press people say, Oh, Hitler, he's always biting the,
他总是咬地毯。”不管怎样，希特勒，他总是咬地毯。不管怎样，希特勒就在那里咬地毯。终于，那天下午，张伯伦来到温泉酒店去了德累斯顿酒店。张伯伦对自己的表现非常满意。张伯伦心想，嗯，我在这里干了一件了不起的事。我做了一项伟大的工作。捷克人已经让步了，你可以拥有苏台德地区。我们将为捷克斯洛伐克其余的边界提供担保。他说，如果能顺便让布拉格方面也签署一份互不侵犯条约以显示你的诚意，那也许是一件好事，然后大功告成。
he's always biting the carpet. Anyway Hitler, it's always biting the carpet. Anyway, so Hitler's there biting the carpet. Finally, that afternoon, Chamberlain comes over to the spa hotel to the Dresden. Chamberlain's delighted with himself. Chamberlain thinks, well, I've done a brilliant thing here. I've done a great bit of work. The checks are given in, you can have the Sudetenland. We will give a guarantee to the Czechoslovakia for the rest of its borders. And he says, maybe it would be a nice thing if you signed a non-aggression pact with Prague as well to show your good intentions and then job done.
我们都可以回家了。万岁。干得漂亮的一天。而希特勒说，我很抱歉。其实，我改变主意了。情况变了，我有更多的要求。他说，我在匈牙利和波兰的朋友对捷克斯洛伐克也有领土要求，我需要让他们满意。而且，仔细想想，我真的不想等捷克人把
We can all go home. Hooray. Brilliant day's work. And Hitler says, I'm sorry. Actually, I've changed my mind. The circumstances have changed and I have more demands. He says, my friends in Hungary and Poland also have territorial demands on Czechoslovakia and I need them to be satisfied. And actually, now that I think about it, I don't really want to wait for the Czechs to give me the
苏台德地区交给我，因为他们每时每刻都在虐待我们的人民。我想现在就把我的军队派进去，拜托。这就是我的计划。所以实际上我要派，我想要现在就把我的军队派进去，拜托。这就是我的计划。所以实际上我打算直接动手了。而张伯伦，他坐在那里，血色从他脸上退去。他说，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，但是，
Sudetenland because they're mistreating our people every hour. I would like to send in my army right now, please. That's my plan. So I'm actually going to send in, I would like to send in my army right now please. That's my plan. So I'm actually just going to go for it. And Chamberlain, he sits there and the kind of blood drains from his features. He says, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but,
然后他基本上气冲冲地回到了自己的酒店，拒绝再出来。所以他们呆在各自互相对立的酒店里。权力博弈。非常明显。第二天，也就是第二天的会议，张伯伦没有出席。他转而送去了一封信，信中说……
but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but And he basically storms off back to his hotel and refuses to come out again. So they're in their kind of rival hotels. Power play. Very, very much. Chamberlain doesn't show up the next day, the next day's meeting. He sends a letter instead and he says...
一封措辞坚定的信。一封措辞坚定的信。他说，英国公众舆论是不会容忍这一点的。这太糟糕了。他说，另外，如果你试图在没有达成协议的情况下强行进入，捷克人会跟你开战的。希特勒回信给他，以希特勒的标准来看，这是一封礼貌的信，最终他们同意在那天晚上会面。回到希特勒的酒店，张伯伦走了进去，希特勒说，其实我改变主意了，他们可以有四天时间。他们
A firmly worded letter. A firmly worded letter. He says, British public opinion will not stand for this. This is very poor. He says, also, the Czechs will fight you if you try to go in without a deal. Hitler sends him a letter back, a polite letter actually by Hitler's standards, and eventually they agree that they will meet that evening. So back at Hitler's hotel, Chamley goes in and Hitler says, I've changed my mind actually, they can have four days. They've
必须在28号之前撤出，然后我就要进去了。他们必须撤出。换句话说，这就是战争。张伯伦对此感到非常震惊。然后又来了一个转折。我们确实喜欢这个系列里的转折。一个人拿着一张便条走进来交给希特勒。希特勒打开这张便条说，天哪，捷克人已经动员了他们的军队。现场陷入了一片长时间的沉默。据报道，张伯伦当时以为希特勒会彻底发狂，并当场下令立刻发动入侵。然后希特勒说，好吧。
got to be out on the 28th and then I'm going days. They've got to be out on the 28th and then I'm going in. They've got to be out. In other words, it's war. Chamberlain is very shocked at this. And then another twist. We do like a twist in this series. A man comes in with a note for Hitler. Hitler opens this note and he says, my God, the Czechs have mobilized their army. And there's this long silence. And Chamberlain apparently thought that Hitler was just going to go absolutely berserk and order an invasion right then and there on the spot. And then Hitler says, fine.
他们可以有更多的时间。他们必须在10月1日之前撤出。我会给他们更多的时间。因为这似乎有更多的时间。他们必须在10月1日之前撤出。我会给他们更多的时间。因为这似乎是一个巨大的悲剧时刻。捷克人表现出了他们的决心。他们动员了。他们大概占据了所有这些要塞。他们随后就这样投降了，这简直太可怕了。是的。你把这看得太私人化了，汤姆，也不是不合理。我的意思是——
They can have a bit more time. They have to be out by the 1st of October. I'll give them more days. Because this seems a bit more time. They have to be out by the first of October. I'll give them more days. Because this seems a great tragic moment. The Czechs have shown their determination. They've mobilised. They've presumably occupied all these fortresses. It just seems awful that they then just surrender it. Yeah. You're taking this very personally, Tom, and not unreasonably. I mean-
我只是觉得这是一件可怕的事情。我的意思是，这是一个可怕的故事，而且我们表现得太糟了，尽管显然没有纳粹那么糟，但是，不，不，我要强调的一点是，我认为我们不是，我们不是其中的头号恶棍。当然，希特勒通过诉诸张伯伦的虚荣心来向他兜售这一点。他对他说，我做出的这个让他们可以呆到10月1日的让步。我这样做完全是为了你，因为我是多么尊重你。我不会为任何其他人做这件事。当然，他很喜欢这个，因为他觉得自己是全场的主角。他再次完成了这场政变。于是张伯伦回到了伦敦。希特勒回到了柏林。希特勒把第二天（也就是星期天）的时间花在了花园里漫步，
I just think it's a terrible thing. I mean, it's a terrible story and we behave so badly, although obviously not as bad as the Nazis, but no, no, it's all point of stress that I think we're not the, we're not the chief villains in this. And of course it sells this to Chamberlain by appealing against Chamberlain's vanity. He says to him, this concession that I'm making that they can have till the 1st of October. I'm only making this for you because of how much I respect you. I wouldn't make this for anybody else. And of course he loves this because he thinks I am the star of the show. I have once again pulled off this coup. So Chamberlain goes back to London. Hitler goes back to Berlin. Hitler spends that next day, which is Sunday strolling in the gardens, the
帝国总理和戈培尔，他对戈培尔说，听着，我们现在最终可能会得到的结果是，我们将获得苏台德地区。我们大概只能维持现状了。然后我们明年或者什么时候再回来收回捷克斯洛伐克的其他领土。与此同时，张伯伦正在会见他的内阁，他们中的许多人实际上真的感到震惊。他们比张伯伦更加震惊，因为希特勒要求了更多。希特勒在某种程度上改变了
Reich Chancellor of Goebbels, and he says, look, what we're going to probably end up with now is we'll get the Sudetenland. We'll probably have to leave it at that. And then we'll come back next year or whenever for the rest of Czechoslovakia. Meanwhile, Chamberlain is meeting his cabinet and many of them are actually really shocked. They're much more shocked than Chamberlain was that Hitler had been asking for more. Hitler had kind of changed
游戏的规则，他们说，好吧，我们要做的就是派贺拉斯·威尔逊，也就是张伯伦的得力助手、公务员，把他派回柏林，我们要告诉希特勒，听着，我们向他施压。你不能攻击捷克人。我们必须达成协议。如果你动用任何武力，那么法国将参战，英国将支持法国。他们采取了相对坚定的立场。而且他们自己也开始为战争做准备了，不是吗？他们是的。完全正确。所以法国人正在派遣军队开往马奇诺防线。
the terms of the game and they say, well, what we'll do is we'll send to Horace Wilson, to Chamberlain's kind of right-hand man, civil servant, send him back to Berlin and we'll tell Hitler, look, we're stressed to him. You cannot attack the Czechs. We have to get the deal. If you use force at all, then the French will enter the war and Britain will support France. They are taking a firmish line on it. And they're starting to kind of get ready for war themselves, aren't they? They are. Exactly. So the French are kind of sending troops up to the Maginot line.
是的。有一种感觉，法英两国正在加紧采取强硬立场。是的，绝对有这种感觉。9月26日、27日，正是在这个时候，他们开始进行真正严肃的准备工作。防空炮火被召集起来，人们开始考虑从城市疏散人员。给儿童发放防毒面具之类的东西。完全正确。所以第二天，也就是9月26日星期一，贺拉斯·威尔逊抵达柏林，他在下午到达，发现希特勒处于一种非常奇特的心情中，因为希特勒那天晚上在柏林的体育宫有一场大型演讲。哦，又是体育。这是一个“体育宫”主题。是的，
Yeah. There is a sense that France and Britain are gearing up to take a strong position. Yes, absolutely there is. 26th, 27th of September, this is when they start making really serious preparations. Anti-aircraft batteries are being called up and there's thoughts about evacuating people from cities. Gas master children and things. Exactly. So the next day, Monday the 26th, Horace Wilson gets to Berlin, gets there in the afternoon and he finds Hitler in a very peculiar mood because Hitler has got a big speech that evening at the Sportpalast in Berlin. Oh, sport again. It's this En-Bus-P theme. Yeah,
没错。会有成群的人涌入体育馆，室内体育馆。带着实心球。希特勒将向2万人发表演讲。他将向他们发表讲话，而希特勒。他当时心情非常（你知道的）暴躁。他对贺拉斯·威尔逊说，我受够了所有这些，比如在酒店里谈判之类的事情。他说，基本上捷克人必须在10月1日之前撤出。要么撤出，要么我就攻击他们。他说，并且我引述原话，如果法国和英国想动手，那就让他们去吧。
exactly. It's going to be all these people in the stadium, indoor stadium. With medicine balls. Hitler's going to address, 20,000 It's going to address them and hit us. He was in a very, you know, sort of grumpy mood. And he says to RS Wilson, I'm sick of all this, like negotiations and hotels and stuff. He says, basically the checks have to be out by the 1st of October. And, or if they're not, I'll attack them. And he says, and I quote, if France and England want to strike, let them go ahead.
我一点也不在乎。他对威尔逊说，如果你不认为我们想打仗，那就来看看我的演讲吧。于是威尔逊去观看了这场演讲，希特勒就像个疯子一样疯狂大喊大叫。我们引述过好几次的美国记者威廉·夏伊勒当时也在场，他说，希特勒在大喊大叫，用我见过的最兴奋的状态尖叫，眼里闪烁着狂热的火焰。他尖叫着关于德意志同胞和受到压迫的德国人，我们要站出来战斗，诸如此类的话。而他的听众，那些狂热的纳粹分子，
I don't give a damn. And he says to Wilson, if you do not think that we want to fight, come and see my speech. So Wilson goes along to see this speech and Hitler is absolutely ranting and raving like a lunatic. William Shire, the American journalist who we've quoted a few times, he was there and he said, Hitler was shouting and shrieking in the worst state of excitement I've ever seen him in with a fanatical fire in his eyes. He's screaming about German-dom and the Germans being oppressed and we will stand and fight and all this kind of thing. And his audience, who are keen Nazis,
彻底疯狂了。每一句话他们都报以掌声，在最后他们齐声高呼了几分钟“元帅之令，吾等遵从”（Führerbefehl, wir folgen），首领的命令，我们跟随，你知道这是一种相当令人不寒栗的场景。这可不是张伯伦向伯明翰的好市民们发表讲话的方式。完全不是。不，完全不是。我挑了一件相当不错的茶具。是的，没错，伯明翰的人民会喜欢某种室内竞技场。我挑了一件相当不错的茶具。是的，没错。伯明翰的人民会喜欢某种室内竞技场。
go absolutely berserk. Every sentence they applaud and at the end they chant for minutes Führerbefehl, wir folgen, Leader Command, we will follow you know this sort of quite chilling scene So not the way that Chamberlain would address the good people of Birmingham Not at all No not at all I've picked up a rather nice tea cosy Yeah exactly, people of Birmingham would enjoy a kind of an indoor arena I've picked up a rather nice tea cozy. Yeah, exactly. People at Birmingham would enjoy a kind of an indoor arena.
它带有一种，他们可以做到的。伯明翰的国立展览中心，伯明翰的国立展览中心。维拉公园球场。但它不是室内的，对吧？那不一样。不，我想不是。无论如何，这件事正在失控。第二天，贺拉斯·威尔逊回到帝国总理府说，听着，我收到了张伯伦的新口信。张伯伦说，不要动用武力。如果你不用武力，
It's with a sort of, they could do it. The NEC, the NEC in Birmingham. Villa Park. It's not indoors though, is it? It's not the same. No, it's not, I suppose. Um, anyway, this is spiraling off. The next day, Horace Wilson goes back to the Reich Chan Street and he says, look, I've had a new message from Chamberlain. Chamberlain says, don't use force. If you don't use force,
有一种情况是，他们可以做到这一点。伯明翰的国家展览中心（NEC）。维拉公园球场。但那不是在室内，对吧？那不一样。不，我想也是。嗯，不管怎样，这有点扯远了。第二天，霍勒斯·威尔逊回到帝国总理府说，听着，我收到了张伯伦的新消息。张伯伦说，不要使用武力。如果你不使用武力，
we will guarantee, Britain will guarantee that the checks will clear out of the Sudetenland. So Britain is actually really now. Yeah, get out of your well prepared fortifications. Yeah. Britain is letting itself down, I think, at this point, Tom, it's fair to say. And Hitler actually is very sulky at this point. He says, well, I don't care what Britain does. I don't care what you do. Or all I care about is the checks have got to be out by the 1st of October. He says, look, I want an answer in two days. Are they going to clear out or not? If they do not clear out, he says, I will smash the checks. He repeats that two more times. I will smash the Czechs.
我们将保证，英国将保证捷克斯洛伐克撤出苏台德地区。所以英国现在真的是……是的，离开你们准备充分的防御工事吧。是的，我认为英国在这个时候让自己失望了，汤姆，这样说很公道。希特勒在这个时候其实非常阴沉。他说，好吧，我不在乎英国做什么。我不在乎你们做什么。我唯一关心的是捷克人必须在10月1日前撤出。他说，听着，我两天内要得到答复。他们到底撤不撤？如果他们不撤，他说，我会粉碎捷克人。他又重复了两遍。我要粉碎捷克人。
And Wilson, who is a very tall man, he kind of draws himself up to his full height. He says, I am warning you, if you do that, and if France feels honor bound to fight in defense of its obligations to Czechoslovakia, quote, the United Kingdom would feel obliged to support her. And Hitler just stares in with those cold blue eyes and he says, if France and England strike, let them do so. It's a matter of complete indifference to me. I am prepared for every eventuality. It is Tuesday today, he says, and by next Monday, we shall all be at war. Yet another cliffhanger. I mean, you've promised cliffhangers and they keep coming.
而威尔逊是个个子很高的人，他挺直了腰板。他说，我警告你，如果你这么做，如果法国觉得有义务履行其防卫捷克斯洛伐克义务而参战，引述他的话说，“英国将觉得有义务支持法国。”希特勒只是用那双冰蓝色的眼睛盯着他说道，如果法英两国要开战，那就让他们来吧。这对我来说完全无所谓。我已经做好了应对一切可能性的准备。他说，今天是星期二，到下周一，我们所有人都会处于战争状态。又是一个悬念。我是说，你承诺过会有悬念，而它们接踵而至。
Like fire from a machine gun, from a Bren gun, perhaps. So let's take a break now and when we come back, we'll find out if Britain and Germany do end up at war in 1938. Hi everyone, it's Catty here from The Rest Is Politics US. Anthony Scaramucci and I want to tell you about our new series that looks at one of the darkest days in modern American history, the Capitol riots of January the 6th. You know, four years have passed since Donald Trump supporters stormed the Capitol building and tried to overturn the 2020 election results. And Cady and I are going to explore the tensions and the personalities at the heart of that storm. Yeah, we're going to look at the whole story, starting off with, of course, the 2020 election
就像机枪的火力一样，也许是布伦机枪。那我们现在休息一下，等我们回来后，来看看英国和德国在1938年是否真的爆发了战争。大家好，我是《政坛其余部分：美国篇》的凯蒂。安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇和我想要告诉大家我们的新系列节目，它聚焦于现代美国历史上最黑暗的日子之一，即1月6日的国会山骚乱。你知道，自特朗普支持者冲进国会大厦并试图推翻2020年大选结果以来，已经过去四年了。凯蒂和我将探讨那场风暴核心的紧张局势和各方人物。是的，我们将审视整个故事，当然，从2020年的选举
result itself, Joe Biden's victory, Donald Trump's attempts to undermine that result right up until January the 6th and those horrifying scenes that all of us watched on television back then. So don't miss it. Go and search The Rest Is Politics US wherever you get your podcast to hear just how Donald Trump tried to defy American democracy. And we've included a clip from the series for you to listen to at the end of this episode. First of all, I must say something to those who have written to my wife or myself in these last weeks to tell us of their gratitude for my efforts and to assure us of their prayers
结果本身开始，乔·拜登的胜利，唐纳德·特朗普直到1月6日试图破坏该结果的举动，以及我们当年在电视上看到的所有那些恐怖的场景。所以千万不要错过。在您获取播客的任何地方搜索《政坛其余部分：美国篇》，听听唐纳德·特朗普是如何试图公然违抗美国民主的。我们在这集节目的末尾为您收录了该系列节目的一段剪辑片段供您收听。首先，我必须对那些在过去几周里写信给我妻子或我本人，表达对我努力的感激并向我们保证为我的成功祈祷的人说几句话。
for my success. Most of these letters have come from women, mothers, or sisters of our own countrymen, but there are countless others besides from France, from Belgium, from Italy, and even from Germany, and it has been heartbreaking to read the growing anxiety they reveal. If I felt my responsibility heavy before to read such letters has made it seem almost overwhelming. How horrible. Fantastic. Incredible it is that we should be digging trenches and trying on gas masks here because of a quarrel in a faraway country between people of whom we know nothing. It seems still more impossible that a quarrel which has already been settled in principle
这些信件大多来自女性，我们同胞的母亲或姐妹，但除此之外还有数不清的信件来自法国、比利时、意大利甚至德国，阅读它们所透露出的日益加重的焦虑令人心碎。如果说我以前觉得自己的责任很重，那么读到这样的信件让这种责任显得几乎难以承受。多么可怕。太奇妙了。难以置信的是，仅仅因为一个遥远国家里我们一无所知的人之间的一场争端，我们就得在这里挖战壕、试戴防毒面具。更让人觉得不可思议的是，一场在原则上已经解决的争端
should be the subject of war. But as long as war has not begun, there is always hope that it may be prevented. a gun, there is always hope that it may be prevented. And you know that I am going to work for peace to the last moment. That is Neville Chamberlain, of course, on Mistakeable Tones, addressing the British people on the night of the 27th of September 1938 with a great rousing piece of oratory that deserves to stand beside the address of Henry V before the Battle of Ashing Core, the colours rung up by Nelson before the Battle of Trafalgar, ringing stuff. Yeah. I mean, listen to that.
竟然会成为战争的导火索。但只要战争还没有爆发，就总有希望阻止它。起码只要还有枪，就总有希望阻止它。你知道我将为和平努力到最后一刻。当然，那是内维尔·张伯伦，用他那无可辨认的语调，在1938年9月27日夜晚向英国人民发表讲话，这是一篇振奋人心的宏大演讲，完全配得上亨利五世在阿金库尔战役前的演讲，配得上纳尔逊在特拉法尔加战役前升起的旗帜，充满震撼力。是的。我是说，听听那个。
Yeah. He's not the most stirring of... No, no, listen to that. You're not going to like, you know, reach for your gun and rush to the battlefront, are you? I mean, Chamberlain, you know, he was never a war leader. He said explicitly, I am a man of peace to the depths of my soul. Armed conflict between nations is a nightmare to me. He's completely upfront about that. And frankly, if you've been through the Great War, that's a completely reasonable position to take.
是的。他可不是最激动人心的……不，不，听听那个。你不会想要，你知道的，去拿枪然后冲向战线，对吧？我是说，张伯伦，你知道，他从来都不是一个战时领袖。他明确表示过，我心灵深处是一个爱好和平的人。国家之间的武装冲突对我是个噩梦。他对此完全是坦诚的。坦白说，如果你经历过大战，这是一个完全合理的立场。
Because that famous line, how horrible, fantastic, incredible it is that we should be digging trenches and trying on gas miles here because of quarrel in a faraway country between people of whom we know nothing, very famous phrase and always used to condemn him. But I mean, there he is absolutely articulating what the mass of people in Britain feel. Yeah, absolutely. And that when Churchill, for instance, who is the most famous anti-apes, says that what Britain is contemplating is shameful, they don't want to hear him say that. No, I think that's absolutely right.
因为那句名言：多么可怕、奇妙、难以置信啊，我们竟然因为一个遥远国家里我们一无所知的人之间的争端，而在这里挖战壕、试戴防毒面具，这是一个非常著名的短语，总是用来谴责他。但我的意思是，他在那里绝对表达了英国广大民众的心声。是的，绝对是。当丘吉尔——例如最著名的反绥靖主义者——说英国正在考虑的事情是可耻的时，他们并不想听到他这么说。不，我认为这绝对是对的。
I think because people probably deep down know that it's shameful. And yet at the same time, they think we must do anything to avoid a rerun of the Great War. They would be worse, wouldn't it? Because it would be, it would be a London and other cities would burn. Exactly. That's exactly. Now, even as Chamberlain is preparing that speech, people are queuing up for gas masks in British town halls and village halls, the first children, blind
我认为是因为人们内心深处可能知道这很可耻。然而与此同时，他们认为我们必须尽一切努力避免大战重演。那会更糟糕，不是吗？因为那将是，那将是伦敦和其他城市化为灰烬。正是如此。没错。现在，甚至在张伯伦准备那篇演讲的同时，人们正在英国的市政厅和村礼堂排队领取防毒面具，第一批儿童，盲童
children are being evacuated from London. They've installed anti-aircraft batteries on Westminster Bridge. There is this sense that a war that nobody wants is coming and will happen within days. Interestingly, the mood in Germany is very similar. So that same day, the 27th, that Chamberlain made that speech, Hitler had arranged for a motorized division to pass through Berlin towards the Czech border and this was basically, he wanted really to impress the diplomatic corps with Germany's readiness for war and Germany's war enthusiasm. And there's an amazing description of it by
正被从伦敦疏散。他们在威斯敏斯特桥上安装了高射炮。有一种感觉：一场无人想要但即将到来的战争将在几天内爆发。有趣的是，德国的氛围非常相似。因此，在张伯伦发表那篇演讲的同一天，即27日，希特勒安排了一支摩托化师穿过柏林开往捷克边境，这基本上是，他非常想让外交界对德国的战争准备和德国的战争热情留下深刻印象。威廉·夏勒——那位经常被提及的记者——对此有一段精彩的描述，他谈到了摩托化师如何穿过坦克、装甲车或无论什么车辆，而人们根本不看它们。人们转过头去，钻进地铁，他们不欢呼，现场一片死寂。他说，这是他见过的针对战争的最惊人的抗议示。事实上，你知道，戈培尔和纳粹最高指挥部，他们对柏林的反应都相当失望。但实际上，即使在纳粹最高指挥部内部，也有巨大的焦虑，对吧？里宾特洛甫可以说是完全，你知道的，他完全赞成。但纳粹最高指挥部的其他成员则在想，哦，不太行，对此不太确定。
William Shire, the journalist who mentioned a lot, and he talks about how the motorized division goes through the tanks or the armored cars or whatever they are, and people won't look at them. People turn away, they duck into the subway, they don't cheer, there is total silence. He says it was one of the most striking demonstrations against war that I've ever seen. And actually, you know, Goebbels and the Nazi High Command, they're all quite disappointed with the Berlin reaction. But actually, even in the Nazi High Command, there is massive anxiety, isn't there? So Ribbentrop is all, you know, he's all in favor of it. But other members of the Nazi high command are thinking, oh, not really, not sure about this.
是的。与英法开战。真的吗，我们准备好了吗？还有德国军队。我是说，他们对此真的很紧张。关于这一点的数据是，在德国的西翼，他们在数量上远远落后于法国军队。是的。就像他们在1939年那样。但在1939年，西方盟国没有一个拥有强大一线防御的独立捷克斯洛伐克。没错。好吧，关于纳粹最高指挥部成员这一重要观点，我们稍后会看到，它即将产生故事中的又一个转折。
Yeah. War with Britain and France. Really, are we ready? And also in the German army. I mean, they're really nervous about it. So the figures on that is that on Germany's Western flank, they are hugely outnumbered by the French army. Yeah. As they would be in 1939. But in 1939, the Western allies did not have an independent Czechoslovakia with strong front-line defences. That's right. Well, we'll see about this point about the Nazi high commanders are really important one and it's about to produce another of these twists in the story.
所以第二天是9月28日星期三，伦敦下议院举行了紧急辩论。此时，大多数人认为我们可能在几小时内就会处于战争状态，因为如果希特勒开绿灯，法国会觉得有荣誉感去保卫捷克斯洛伐克，而我们会觉得有荣誉感紧随法国之后。所以张伯伦正在发表这篇长篇大论，这篇略显沉闷的演讲，向同僚议员们解释整个背景故事、与希特勒的所有谈判、所有这些都化为泡影，诸如此类的事情。
So the next day is Wednesday, the 28th of September, the house of comments in London holds an emergency debate. And at this point, most people think we will probably be at war within, could be within hours, because if Hitler gives the go ahead, France will feel honor bound to defend Czechoslovakia and we will feel honor bound to fall in behind France. So Chamberlain is giving this enormous speech, this slightly plodding speech to these fellow MPs explaining the whole backstory, all the negotiations with Hitler, all being for nothing, all this kind of thing.
然后有一个惊人的，我是说，这真的是一个惊人的时刻。他递过一张纸条。它沿着长椅顺着链条传过来，一张纸，一张纸，坐在他身边的约翰·西蒙把这张纸递了过来，这是来自英国驻柏林大使的消息，他停止了说话。他读了读，停顿了一下，清了清嗓子，非常具有戏剧性。然后他说，我对议院还有话要说。他说，我接到一个邀请。
And then there's an amazing, I mean, it really is an amazing moment. He has passed a note. It kind of comes down the chain along the bench and a piece of paper, piece of paper, so John Simon who's sitting next to him hands in this piece of paper and it's news from the British ambassador in Berlin and he stops talking. He reads it, pauses, clears his throat, very theatrical. And then he says, I have something further to say to the house. He says, I've got an invitation.
我收到了希特勒元首的邀请，让我在明天上午去慕尼黑见他。他还邀请了墨索里尼阁下和达拉第先生。墨索里尼阁下已经接受了，毫无疑问，法国总理达拉第先生也会接受。他说，我不用告诉你们我的回答是什么。也就是说我一定会去。当人们听到这个消息时，爆发了巨大的如释重负的欢呼声。我们时代的和平。我是说，人们简直在大喊大叫，因为人们将此归功于张伯伦，对吧？他们说他呼吁了
I have an invitation from Hare Hitler to meet him in Munich tomorrow morning. He's also invited Signor Mussolini and Monsieur de Ladier. Signor Mussolini has accepted, I've no doubt, Monsieur de Ladier, he's the French prime minister, will also accept. I need not tell you, he says, what my answer will be. As in I'm definitely going to go. And when people hear this, there's this colossal roar of relief. Peace in our time. I mean, people are literally shouting, because people credit Chamberlain with this, right? They say he called to, he called for
和平直到最后一刻，而希特勒退让了，他们在欢呼，挥舞着议事文件。人们简直在呐喊，感谢首相，为首相万岁之类的话。辩论被提前结束了。人们围着张伯伦，拍着他的后背。事实上，最后一个上去和他握手的是温斯顿·丘吉尔，他对他说，一路顺风。接着他出发了，他将踏上这次使命，试图为欧洲带来和平。而这背后的其实是某个角色的干预，你
peace to the last moment and Hitler has blinked and they are cheering, they're waving their order papers. People are literally shouting, thank God for the prime minister, hurrah for the prime minister and all this kind of thing. And the debate is brought to a premature conclusion. People are crowding around Chamberlain, they pat him on the back. And actually the last person to go up and shake his hand is Winston Churchill, who says to him, Godspeed. And off he goes, he's going to go off on this mission to try and, and bring peace to Europe. And actually what lies behind this is an intervention from a character who's, you
知道的，我们的听众对我很熟悉。他在过去几集里一直非常安静——坦白说，他一直在外狩猎。一个坏人，但也是一个令人难忘的人，因为我们终于迎来了《历史的其余部分》的回归，那就是穿着汗流浃背的白色西装、身躯庞大的赫尔曼·戈陵。所以大约在这个时候，意大利外交部长偶然遇到了戈陵，并在他身上发现了一点阿尔·卡彭的影子。所以此时的戈陵是一个身材极其高大的人。如果你看到他穿这套西装，这套西装对他来说小了好几个尺码。他戴着各种镶钻的纳粹万字旗形状的领带夹
know, he's well known to our listeners. He's been very quiet in the last few episodes. I think it's fair to say- He's been off hunting. A bad man, but a memorable man, because we finally welcome back to the rest of history, the sweating white suited bulk of Herman Goering. So it's around this time that the Italian foreign minister bumps into Göring and finds in him a slight suggestion of Al Capone. So Göring at this point is an absolutely enormous man. If you see him in this suit, the suit is like multiple sizes too small for him. He's got all kinds of diamond studded tie pins in the shape of swastikas
之类的东西。是的。所以本来就容易出汗的戈陵，过去几天像野兽一样汗流浃背，因为他对欧洲战争的想法感到极度的恐慌。他认为欧洲战争是疯了。我们要得到苏台德地区了。我们为什么要跟法英开战？他对里宾特洛甫怀有绝对的激情般的痛恨。他不断对里宾特洛甫说，别再要求战争了，你这个傻瓜。有一次他们大吵了一架。戈陵说，好吧，我懂什么是战争。他说，如果希特勒想要战争，我将坐上飞往英国的第一架飞机。但他对里宾特洛甫说，好吧，我会确保你被绑在我身边的那个
and things. Yeah. So Göring who's a sweaty man as it is, he's been sweating like a beast for the last few days because he's in a massive funk about the idea of a European war. He thinks the European war is bonkers. We're going to get the Sudetenland. What do we want to fight France and Britain for? He hates Ribbentrop with an absolute passion. He keeps saying to Ribbentrop, stop asking for a war, you fool. And at one point they have a massive row. Goering says, well, I know what war is. He says, if Hitler wants a war, I'll be on the first plane over Britain. But he says to Ribbentrop, well, I'll make sure you're strapped in next to me on that
飞机上。想象一下如果你在那架飞机上，多么可怕的噩梦啊。我要坐在谁旁边？他太庞大了，不是吗？以至于会把那架飞机压坠毁。想象一下如果你和戈陵坐同一架飞机，那是多么可怕的噩梦。谁会坐在你旁边？他在中间，夹在戈陵和里宾特洛甫之间。真是个噩梦。无论如何，实际上发生了什么？戈陵背着希特勒行事。他向墨索里尼发送了信息，并向伦敦和巴黎发送了非正式信息。他对墨索里尼说，我认为你应该呼吁，如果你呼吁召开和平会议，你是希特勒的盟友。希特勒将不得不顺从。
plane. Imagine if you were on that plane with, what a terrible nightmare that is. Who am I going to sit next to? He's so large, isn't he? That it's going to crash that plane. Imagine if you were on that plane with what a terrible nightmare that is. Who might be sitting next to you? He's so large isn't he that it's going to crash the plane. I'm in the middle of the three between Goering and Ribbentrop. What a nightmare. Anyway, what actually happens? Goering goes behind Hitler's back. He sends messages to Mussolini and informal messages to London and Paris. And he says to Mussolini, I think you should call, if you call for a peace conference, you're Hitler's ally. Hitler will have to go along with it.
事实上，如果墨索里尼呼吁召开和平会议，这是希特勒在战争问题上稍微退让而又不会丢太多面子的绝妙方法。他看起来会是一个在最终分析中愿意讲道理的人，因为他顺从了他好哥们的请求。所以这正是发生的事情。那天早些时候，意大利大使去见了希特勒，并说，哦，领袖认为你可以推迟入侵，与英国人再开一次会，把法国人也请来。而希特勒有点被困住了。你知道的，
And actually, if Mussolini calls for a peace conference, it's a brilliant way for Hitler to kind of back down a bit on the war thing without losing too much face. He will look like a person who in the final analysis was prepared to be reasonable because he gave into his great pal's request. And so this is exactly what happens. Earlier that day, the Italian ambassador had gone to see Hitler and said, oh, the Duce thinks you could postpone the invasion, have one more meeting with the British, invite the French along. And Hitler's kind of trapped. You know,
他不能，虽然他本可以完全忽视墨索里尼，但那会危及他与欧洲最大盟友的联盟。所以希特勒说，好吧，行。随便吧。好吧。这就是信号。这就是臭名昭著的慕尼黑和平会议背后的原因，该会议将于第二天开始。我想此时，我们一直在为慕尼黑做铺垫，但实际上
he can't, when he could ignore Mussolini completely, but that would risk his alliance with his biggest ally in Europe. So Hitler says, yeah, fine. Whatever. Yeah. All right. So that is the cue. That is what lies behind the infamous Munich Peace Conference, which begins the very next day. And I think at this point, we've been leading up to Munich, but it's actually
值得停下来指出一个经常被忽略的观点。如果你一直在听他们的故事，此时应该很明显，慕尼黑并不是那个伟大的转折点。不，因为背叛已经发生了。英法两国基本上已经告诉捷克人交出苏台德地区，并明确表示他们不会为苏台德地区而战。所以事实上，慕尼黑发生的事情不是张伯伦和达拉第的退让。而是希特勒的退让。是希特勒因为戈陵和墨索里尼在背后搞鬼，而没有将他的战争强加给捷克人和世界。
worth pausing to make a point that I think is often lost. If you've been listening to all their story, it should be obvious at this point that Munich is not the great turning point. No, because the betrayal has already happened. The British and French have already basically told the Czechs to give over the Sudetenland and made it very clear they will not fight for the Sudetenland. So actually, what's happened at Munich is not Chamberlain and de Lattier backing down. It's Hitler backing down. It's Hitler not forcing his war on the Czechs and on the world because of Goering and Mussolini going behind
张伯伦并没有放弃任何他几周前就已经放弃的东西。这对于希特勒未来愿意听取戈陵关于外交政策的任何意见来说是致命的。所以他称他为老太婆，不是吗？没错，他确实这么叫。对此大发雷霆。希特勒觉得自己被欺骗了，这种感觉将贯穿这集的其余部分以及下周的节目。希特勒觉得自己被剥夺了战争的失落感。现在张伯伦对此毫无察觉。
his back. Chamberlain is not going to give away anything that he hadn't given away weeks earlier actually. And this is fatal for Hitler's willingness in future to listen to anything that Goering has to say on foreign policy. So he calls him an old woman, doesn't he? Exactly, he does. Furious about it. Hitler feels cheated and this will run through the rest of this episode and indeed next week's episodes. Hitler's sense of being cheated of his war. Now Chamberlain doesn't get this at all.
张伯伦仍然认为我是这个故事的主角。我是说，英国的每个人都有点把他当作故事的主角来对待。当他第二天飞走时，整个内阁都来到机场为他送行。澳大利亚、加拿大、爱尔兰和南非的高级专员都来为他送行。一路顺风，祝你好运，诸如此类的东西。他们认为他是这一切的缔造者，而他绝对不是。张伯伦对此乐此不疲。
Chamberlain still thinks I'm the star of this story. I mean, everyone in Britain kind of treats him like he's the star of the story. When he flies out the next day, the whole cabinet comes to the aerodrome to see him off. The high commissioners of Australia, Canada, Ireland, and South Africa, they all come to see him off. Godspeed, good luck, all that kind of thing. They think he is the architect of this, which he absolutely isn't. And Chamberlain loves it.
他说，他对镜头有这样一句名言。当我还是个小男孩时，我总是重复：如果一开始没有成功，那就再试、再试、再试一次。这就是我在做的。当我回来时，我希望我能像《亨利四世》中的霍茨伯那样说：从这株荆棘危险中，我们摘取了安全之花。当然，霍茨伯在随后的战斗中战败了。他确实这么说过，这不是个好兆头。这不是个好兆头。另一方面，想到我们曾经有过随机引用《亨利四世》的首相，感觉还是挺不错的。
He says, he has this quotation to the cameras. When I was a little boy, I used to repeat, if at first you don't succeed, try, try, try again. That's what I'm doing. When I come back, I hope I will be able to say as hot spur says in Henry the fourth out of this nettle danger, we pluck this flower safety. Of course, hot spur lost the subsequent battle. He did indeed say not a good omet. It's not a good omet. On the other hand, it's kind of nice to think we once had prime ministers would randomly randomly quote from Henry IV.
是的，我无法想象斯塔默会这样做。不，不，我看不出斯塔默会这样做。因此，他一在慕尼黑降落，会议立刻就开始了。他们在希特勒的慕尼黑总部开会，被称为“元首宫”，这是一座专为纳粹党建造的巨大的新古典主义建筑。它不是一家酒店，但基本上有那种氛围。它有那种氛围。里面到处都是大理石和鲜花，我敢肯定里宾特洛甫还在里面喷了古龙水。
Yeah, I can't imagine Stammer doing that. No, no, I can't see Stammer doing that. So as soon as he lands in Munich, the conference opens straight away. They're meeting in Hitler's Munich headquarters, the Führerbau, it's called, which is this huge neoclassical building that was built especially for the Nazi party. It's not a hotel, but it's basically got that vibe. It's got that vibe. It's full of kind of marble and flowers and I'm sure Ribbentrop has sprayed it with Eau de Calais.
香槟。因此，代表团径直来到希特勒的私人书房，他们围坐在一张俾斯麦肖像下的小桌子旁。想必有一个著名的会议，对吧，迪斯雷利去过的那次？是的，柏林。迪斯雷利被视为在俾斯麦的老巢中直面对方并整顿欧洲的人。我想这一定在张伯伦的脑海中，他正在扮演那个角色。因为那是“带着荣誉的和平，我们时代的和平”这句话的来源。他引用的是1878年左右迪斯雷利的话，我想是那次。所以他们围坐在桌旁。
Champagne. So the delegates all go straight up to Hitler's private study and they're sitting around these sort of little table beneath a portrait of Bismarck. And presumably there's a famous conference isn't there where Disraeli goes? Yeah, Berlin. And Disraeli is seen as the guy who has bearded Bismarck in his lair and sorted Europe out. And I get that must surely be on Chamberlain's mind that he's playing that role. Because that's where the Peace with Honor, Peace in our Time line comes from. He's quoting Disraeli after 1878 I think it was. So they're around this table.
希特勒在那里。墨索里尼在那里。爱德华·达拉第，我们还没提到他。他实际上参加过凡尔登战役。所以他是一个严肃的人，但他非常非常痛苦。每个人都说他看起来像一只蜗牛，我其实也能看出一点。我听说希特勒和戈培尔认为他比张伯伦更有气场。是吗？这可能说明不了什么，但他们确实那么认为。是的。好吧，我的意思是，谁会，谁会不同意希特勒和戈培尔呢？他们认为他比张伯伦更有气场，是吗？是吗？这可能说明不了什么，但他们确实那么认为，是的。
Hitler is there. Mussolini is there. Edward de Ladier, we haven't mentioned him. He had actually fought at the Battle of Verdun. So he's a serious person, but he's very, very miserable. Everyone said he looked like a snail, which I can kind of see actually. I gather Hitler and Goebbels thought he was more impressive than Chamberlain though. Did they? May not be saying much, but they thought he was. Yeah. Well, I mean, who would, who would ever disagree with Hitler and Goebbels thought he was more impressive than Chamberlain though. Did they? May not be saying much, but they thought he was, yeah.
好吧，我的意思是，谁会不同意希特勒和戈培尔？他们真是伟大的性格裁判官啊。但他们对他们认为谁是……我想他们会的，是的，他们会的。现在当然那些不在场的人，捷克人。没有人邀请捷克人。希特勒说过，捷克人绝对不能来。捷克人对此感到愤怒。
Well I mean, who would ever disagree with Hitler and Goebbels? What tremendous judges of character they are. But they'd have a sense of who they thought were. I suppose they would, yeah, they would. Now of course the people who aren't there, the Czechs. No one's invited the Czechs. Hitler has said, there's no way the Czechs are coming. And the Czechs are outraged at this.
张伯伦对捷克总统爱德华·贝奈斯说，嗯，我代表你。我的意思是，这就像典型的英国傲慢。事实上，关于慕尼黑会议，在阅读相关资料之前我并不太了解。那真是一团糟。就像德国的效率一样。其实不是。他们连足够的钢笔和铅笔都没有。他们忘了带任何纸张。那简直是一团糟。
And Chamberlain said to Edvard Benes, the Czech president, well, I'll represent you. I mean, that's like classic British arrogance. The conference actually, I didn't really know this about the Munich conference until reading up on it. It was a complete shambles. It was like German efficiency. It was not. They didn't have enough pens and pencils. They forgot to bring any paper. It was a complete mess. not. They didn't have enough pens and pencils. They forgot
记不清带任何纸张了。那真是一团糟，而且电话也坏了。里宾特洛甫对电话坏了气急败坏。他说这对德国来说是个极大的难堪。英国人不得不回去使用他们酒店里的电话，因为会场的电话根本不好用。无论如何，正如我们所说，我觉得慕尼黑会议奇怪的地方在于它太出名了，但它又如此流于形式，因为基本上真的没什么好决定的。他们已经决定了，他们已经决定希特勒要夺取苏台德地区，英法将听任他这样做，就是这样。他们花了13个小时来讨论所有的技术细节。张伯伦和达拉第显然有点情绪低落。希特勒只是觉得无聊。他不会说德语以外的任何语言，所以他听不懂发生了什么。但我告诉你谁会说很多语言，谁才是真正的语言大师，就像你一样，非常像我，非常相似的人，记者，某种昂首阔步。谢谢。
to bring any paper. It was a complete mess and the phones didn't work properly. Ribbentrop was going mad about the phones not working. He said it was a great embarrassment for Germany. And the British had to go back and use the phones in their hotel because the phones didn't work properly. Anyway, as we said, I think the weird thing about the Munich conference is so well known, but it's such a non-event because it's basically just kind of nothing to decide really. They've decided, they've already decided Hitler's going to take the Sudetenland, Britain and France are going to let him do it and that's it. And it takes them 13 hours to go through all the technicalities. Chamberlain and de Ladier are obviously a little bit downbeat. Hitler's just bored. He doesn't
外表相似。拜托，墨索里尼会说德语，他会说英语，而且法语流利。所以墨索里尼就像是在做一点翻译工作。他玩得很开心。
speak any language but German, so he can't understand what's going on. But I tell you who does speak a lot of languages, who is a real master of tongues, like you, very like me, very similar people, journalist, certain strut. Thanks. Yeah. Physical resemblance. I mean, come on, Mussolini speaks German, he speaks English and he's fluent in French. So Mussolini is like doing a bit of translating. He's having a great time.
是的，他是这么做的吗？他就像一个新泽西州餐馆里的伙计。欢迎。欢迎。欢迎。因此，在大约9月30日凌晨两点，协议达成了。
Yeah. Is that how he's doing it? He's doing it like a guy from a restaurant in New Jersey. Yeah. Welcome. Welkommen. Bienvenue. So at about two o'clock in the morning of the 30th of September, the deal is done.
捷克人将有10天时间撤出苏台德地区。10月10日，德军将长驱直入。当你提到捷克人时，我的意思是，这不仅仅指捷克军队。字面意思就是捷克人。嗯，这并不明确，对吧？许多捷克人逃离了苏台德地区。并没有明文规定他们必须离开。而且他们也没有获得任何补偿之类的东西。
The Czechs will have 10 days to get out to the Statenland. 10th of October, the Germans will march in. And when you say the Czechs, I mean, you mean it's not just the Czech army. It's literally the Czechs. Well, this is unclear, right? A lot of Czechs flee the Sudetenland. It's not laid down that they have to. And they're not being offered any compensation or anything.
不，不，我不这么认为。我的意思是，这似乎是个糟糕的协议。这对捷克人来说太糟糕了。这不是一桩好买卖。我看不出有任何积极的一面。这是一桩非常糟糕的交易。无论如何，协议已经达成。你现在抱怨也没有用了。他们拿出来，他们说有一个盛大的签字仪式。希特勒把他的笔蘸进他专门准备的
No, no, I don't think so. I mean, that seems a bad deal. It's a terrible check. It's not a good deal. I see no positive there. It's a very bad deal. Anyway, the deal is done. There's no point in you complaining about it now. They bring out, they say there has a big signing. Hitler dips his pen in the special inkwell that he
墨水瓶里去签署协议。墨水瓶里没有墨水。里宾特洛甫的脸气急败坏。又一个笑话。弗洛伊德会对此怎么看？是的。对德国来说又是一场灾难。事实上，我在YouTube上看了最后的场景，百代新闻短片。希特勒看起来精疲力竭。墨索里尼显然玩得很开心。但事实上，另一个玩得很开心的人是戈陵。戈陵穿着这套极其紧绷的白色西装，讲着笑话，拍着别人的后背之类的事情。因为这当然是，他把这视为他个人的胜利。
has to sign the deal. There's no ink in the inkwell. Ribbentrop's face furious. Another fraud. What would Freud make of that? Yeah. Another disaster for Germany. And actually I watched the final scenes, the Pathé newsreels on YouTube. Hitler looks exhausted. Mussolini is having a brilliant time clearly. But actually the person who's also loving it is Goering. Goering is in this unbelievably tight white suit and he's kind of cracking jokes and slapping people on the back and stuff. Because of course this is, he regards this as a victory for himself.
尽管他和英国大使内维尔·亨德森爵士是好哥们。所以他们一起去打猎了。没错。他玩得很开心。不过希特勒非常郁闷和沮丧。他实际上没有得到他想要的，那就是他的战争。第二天，他和张伯伦进行了最后一次会面。他们显然很累，因为熬到了很晚。张伯伦进去见他，而张伯伦……
Although his big mates with Sir Neville Henderson, the British ambassador. So they've gone out shooting. Exactly. He's having a wonderful time. Hitler though is very gloomy and despondent. He's actually not got what he wanted, which was his war. And the next day he has one last meeting with Chamberlain. They're obviously very tired because they've been up until very late. Chamberlain goes in to see him and Chamberlain...
这就是他出示他那张纸的地方。一张纸。张伯伦给了他一个惊喜。我们将永远是朋友。每个人都会幸福，鲜花会盛开，一切都会好起来的。我们保证我们永远不会开战。英国和德国将永远不会再次爆发战争。再也不会有仙女死去了。现在，在罗伯特·哈里斯关于慕尼黑的小说中，这是一部精彩的小说，他将此描绘成相当……张伯伦显然对这张纸倾注了巨大的情感
This is where he presents his piece of paper. Piece of paper. Chamberlain surprises him. We will be friends forever. Everyone will be happy and the flowers will come and everything. We promise that we will never go to war. Britain and Germany will never go to war again with each other again. No fairy will ever die again. Now in Robert Harris's novel about Munich, which is brilliant, he presents this as quite a, Chamberlain isn't clearly emotionally
投入。不管怎样，它实际上确实是一个有用的政治道具，因为我认为那张纸在绥靖政策的衰落中很重要。增强了英国人的决心。增强了英国人的决心。希特勒做出了他后来打破的明确承诺。所以我认为它确实是一张重要的纸。希特勒当时看到那张纸时。他对此感到迷惑不解。他认为这完全是浪费时间。他说，当然，我签。
invested a lot in this piece of paper. If nothing else, it actually is actually a useful political prop because I think it is important that piece of paper in the decline of appeasement. Stiffening British. Stiffening British resolve. Hitler has made an explicit promise that he goes on to break. And so I think it does, it is an important piece of paper. Hitler at the time sees the piece of paper. He's baffled by it. He thinks it's complete waste of time. He says, sure, I'll sign it.
我是说，我不在乎。他签了这张纸，里宾特洛甫事后问他，那张纸是什么？希特勒说它没有任何意义，我认为这不对。我认为这在英国公众舆论方面真的很重要，因为这就是张伯伦回到赫斯顿机场时挥舞的那张纸，那张上面有他的名字以及我的名字的纸，你知道的，那个承诺。带着荣誉的和平，我们时代的和平。
I mean, I don't care. He signs this piece of paper and Ribbentrop says to him afterwards, what was that piece of paper? And Hitler says it was of no significance whatsoever, which I think is wrong. I think it really mattered in terms of British public opinion, because this is the piece of paper that Chamberlain waves when he gets back to Heston Aerodrome, the paper that bears his name upon it as well as mine, you know, the promise. Peace with honour, peace for our time.
这当然是张伯伦回来时说的话，他受到了巨大民众的欢迎，并被邀请登上白金汉宫的阳台。他是英国乃至整个英语世界当之无愧的英雄。更广泛地说，有来自美国、澳大利亚、加拿大的祝贺信息，干得好。但大概没有来自布拉格的。但绝对没有来自布拉格的。关于协议的消息在同一天早上，即9月30日传到了布拉格。
Which is of course what Chamberlain says when he comes back and he's greeted by great crowds and he's invited onto the balcony of Buckingham Palace. And he's the absolute hero of the hour in Britain and indeed in the English speaking world. More generally there are messages from America, from Australia, Canada, well done. But presumably not from Prague. But not from Prague at all. The news of the deal reached Prague on that same morning, so the 30th of September.
贝奈斯总统正在洗澡时，消息传到了他耳中。他非常有先见之明地说道：这是一场自食其果的背叛。他们以为能以我们的牺牲免于战争和革命，他们大错特错了。他的确考虑过无论如何都要抵抗。所以这就是你那个问题的答案。捷克人确实考虑过无论如何都要抵抗，他们曾考虑向苏联寻求帮助。最终他们决定，听着，我们注定会失败。我们不会让我们的人民承受那么多苦难。他们说，贝奈斯说，我们被打败了，不是被希特勒，而是被我们的
President Benes was in having a bath when the news was brought to him. And he said, very presciently, he said, It's a betrayal which will be its own punishment. They think they will save themselves from war and revolution at our expense and they are wrong. He did think about fighting anyway. So this is your answer to your question. The Czechs did think about fighting anyway and they thought about asking the Soviet Union for their help. And eventually they decided, look, we're bound to lose. We're not going to condemn our people to so much suffering. And they said, Benes said, we've been defeated not by Hitler, but by our
朋友，我们所谓的朋友。布拉格爆发了大规模示威，人们高喊不要这样做。但他们当然还是照做了。德国军队跨越边境，正如希特勒所计划的那样，大批苏台德德国人抛洒鲜花、行纳粹礼以及诸如此类的事情。这就是你关于捷克人的另一个问题的答案。所以苏台德地区发生了大规模的人口外逃。当德军越过边境时，大约有25,000名捷克人已经逃离。在接下来的两个月里……
friends, our so-called friends. There are huge demonstrations in Prague, people saying don't do it. But of course they do do it. The German army crosses the border, just as Hitler had planned, huge crowds of Sudeten Germans throwing their flowers and giving Nazi salutes and all this kind of thing. And here's the answer to your other question about the Czechs. So there's a huge population flight from the Sudetenland. By the time the Germans crossed the border, about 25,000 Czechs had already fled. And in the next two months... Leaving their possessions. Leaving everything. You know, the classic thing of people with their thing on carts. With wheelbarrows and things.
抛弃了他们的财产。抛弃了一切。你知道的，人们带着推车之类东西的经典画面。推着独轮车之类的。
Yeah. Exactly. And in the next two months, another 150,000 people, including obviously the Jewish population of the city of Ateneb, who know exactly what Nazism will mean for them. This was a catastrophe for Czechoslovakia. They lost three million people. They lost 11,000 square miles of territory. They lost a fifth of their industrial production. And crucially, they lost those frontier defenses that you've been talking about, which have now fallen to
是的。正是如此。在接下来的两个月里，又有15万 人流离失所，其中显然包括艾讷布市的犹太人口，他们非常清楚纳粹主义对他们意味着什么。这对捷克斯洛伐克来说是一场灾难。他们失去了300万人口。他们失去了11,000平方英里的领土。他们失去了五分之一的工业产量。最重要的是，他们失去了你刚才一直在谈论的那些边境防御工事，而这些工事现在甚至没有开一枪就落入了
the Germans without a single shot being fired. So if the Germans do want to finish the job, if they want to go into the deeper into Bohemia, nothing to stop them at all. What is worse or as bad Hungary and Poland both nibbled at the borders of Czechoslovakia and took more bits as we'll talk about the Polish bit next week and Czechoslovakia, the whole balance of it was kind of upset. So the Slovaks demanded more autonomy. Basically they end up with a much weaker more federalized country. There's a
德国人手中。所以如果德国人真的想完成这项工作，如果他们想深入波希米亚，没有任何东西可以阻挡他们。更糟糕的是——或者同样糟糕的是——匈牙利和波兰都蚕食了捷克斯洛伐克的边境，夺取了更多的领土，我们下周会谈到波兰的部分，而捷克斯洛伐克的整体平衡有点被打乱了。因此斯洛伐克人要求更多的自治权。基本上他们最终得到了一个更弱、更联邦化的国家。有一个
Czech bit, there's an autonomous Slovakia, and the Far East, there's a bit called subcarpathian Ruthenia, which is now in Ukraine, which is going to have a Ukrainian majority. And there the German consul is basically the big man. So in other words, the process of dismemberment has begun, and Hitler can basically move in to claim the rest whenever he fancies it. And obviously, this is terrible news for the Czechs, but it's also, I mean, it's not great news for the conspirators and the German high command, is it? No.
捷克部分，一个自治的斯洛伐克，以及远东一个叫做喀尔巴阡山以南鲁塞尼亚的地区，现在属于乌克兰，那里将有一个乌克兰多数族裔。在那里，德国领事基本上成了大人物。换句话说，肢解的过程已经开始，希特勒基本上可以在他高兴的时候随时搬进去占领其余部分。显然，这对捷克人来说是个可怕的消息，但这也是，我的意思是，对密谋者和德国最高指挥部来说也不是什么好消息，对吧？没有。
So that plot, which we talked about last time, Ludwig Beck, Admiral Canaris, Oster, these other characters who were thinking about moving against Hitler, that's completely fizzled out. Hitler's done it again. Another foreign policy coup. So, you know, there's no mileage for a conspiracy against him. And they say Chamberlain saved Hitler. You know, we would have moved against him,
所以我们上次谈到的那个阴谋，路德维希·贝克、卡纳里斯海军上将、奥斯特以及其他考虑对希特勒采取行动的人物，已经彻底流产了。希特勒又成功了。又一次外交政策政变。所以，你知道的，针对他的阴谋已经没有空间了。他们说张伯伦拯救了希特勒。你知道，我们本会对付他的，
whether that's the case and whether it would have worked, I don't know. But they definitely think that Chamberlain saved Hitler. And that is the last coordinated conspiracy against Hitler within Germany until 1944? Until 1944. It's a kind of ancestor of the Stauffenberg plot, which is what slightly leads me to think it probably wouldn't have worked because of course the Stauffenberg plot fizzles out within a day. I think it might have worked had the Czechs held out, had this resulted in kind of economic meltdown, which was coming anyway. Obviously the absorption of Czechoslovakia means that
不管是不是这样，以及它是否会成功，我不知道。但他们绝对认为张伯伦拯救了希特勒。那是德国境内对希特勒的最后一次有组织的阴谋，直到1944年？直到1944年。它是陶芬格阴谋的某种先驱，这让我稍微认为它可能不会成功，因为陶芬格阴谋当然在一天之内就流产了。我认为如果捷克人坚持下来，如果这导致了无论如何都会到来的经济崩溃，它可能会成功。很明显，吞并捷克斯洛伐克意味着
economic meltdown is staved off, but I think circumstances might have been different. Well, we'll never know, will we? I mean, that's the thing. As it is, people across Eastern Europe in particular think, you know, Hitler, Hitler wins, Hitler is the master now. So two countries in particular, Hungary and Romania, from this point onwards, they basically say, well, it's not much point in this, all the French trying to build all these alliances, they're a complete waste of time.
经济崩溃被避免了，但我认为情况可能会有所不同。好吧，我们永远不会知道，对吧？这就是问题所在。就目前而言，特别是东欧各地的人们认为，你知道，希特勒，希特勒赢了，希特勒现在是主人了。因此，尤其是两个国家，匈牙利和罗马尼亚，从这一刻起，他们基本上说，好吧，这没什么意义，法国人试图建立的所有这些联盟，它们完全是浪费时间。
They never fight for you. Hit, you know, we want to be in with the Germans. They're the big, they're the big men now. But the person who isn't happy is Hitler. He wanted his war and he's been, he's been betrayed as he sees it by Mussolini and by Goering and by Chamberlain. But he has stared into the eyes of Chamberlain and de Ladié and he thinks that he sees weakness
他们从不为你而战。希特勒，你知道，我们想和德国人在一起。他们才是大人物。但唯一不高兴的人是希特勒。他想要他的战争，但他觉得被墨索里尼、戈陵和张伯伦背叛了。但他直视了张伯伦和达拉第的眼睛，他认为他看到了软弱
and pusillanimity and cowardice. Yes. And that therefore he can take them on. I mean, he calls them worms, doesn't he? Little worms. I've seen them. I've seen how contemptible they are. And of course, that is not actually the right... So he is mistaken as well, because actually when Chamberlain gets back, I mean, he does all his paper waving and going on the balcony of Buckingham Palace and things, but he does also say, we've got to rearm, you know, we've got to press the accelerator on this.
、怯懦和懦弱。是的。因此他可以拿下他们。我的意思是，他称他们为蠕虫，不是吗？小蠕虫。我见过他们。我见识过他们是多么卑鄙。当然，那其实并不是正确的……所以他也错了，因为实际上当张伯伦回来时——我的意思是，他挥舞着纸张，登上白金汉宫阳台做那些事，但他也确实说过，我们必须重新武装，你知道，我们必须在这上面踩油门。
Yes, he does. He absolutely does. I think in the last episode, I quoted Ian Kershaw saying about how cunning Hitler's foreign policy coups had been, how brilliantly planned, how ruthlessly the propaganda had been cranked up. What a great judge of timing Hitler had been. This is really the first point at which I think you can say his instincts completely begin to desert him. He believes his own publicity and he misreads the situation. I think you're dead right.
是的，他确实这么做了。他绝对这么做了。我想在上一集里，我引用了伊恩·克肖的话，谈到希特勒的外交政策政变是多么狡猾，计划多么巧妙，宣传被无情地煽动到什么程度。希特勒对时机的把握是多么出色。这真的是你认为他的直觉开始完全抛弃他的第一个点。他相信了自己的宣传，并误读了局势。我认为你完全正确。
I think he completely misreads Britain and France after this. I mean, all the stuff like they will never fight, they're weak, all that. He's dead wrong. He's running out of time now before they do fight. I think, and he, and he doesn't see that. I think he doesn't see that at all. One thing about Hitler though, he feels that the German people have let him down. He's really discomforted that there was not more enthusiasm for war in the autumn of 1938. He was shocked that people cheered Chamberlain as he drove through the streets.
我认为他在那之后完全误读了英法。我的意思是，诸如他们永远不会开战、他们很弱之类的一切言论。他大错特错了。在他们真正开战之前，他的时间不多了。我认为，而他，他没有看到这一点。我认为他根本没有看到这一点。不过关于希特勒的一点是，他觉得德国人民让他失望了。1938年秋天，人们对战争没有表现出更多热情，这让他感到非常不安。人们在张伯伦驱车穿过街道时为他欢呼，这让他感到震惊。
So they've let Germany down, they've let Hitler down, but worst of all, they've let themselves down. They've let themselves down, they've let the school down. And he says, so I wonder whether the pogrom of Kristallnacht, the night of the broken glass against the Jewish population of Germany, which happens just a few weeks afterwards, November 1938. We did an episode on it in our previous season. The violence of that, I think, and the violence for which Hitler, you know, he personally was responsible, he ordered it. I wondered at some level whether his sense of frustration that he hasn't got his war,
所以他们让德国失望了，他们让希特勒失望了，但最糟糕的是，他们让自己失望了。他们让自己失望了，他们让学校失望了。他说，所以我怀疑1938年11月，就在几周后发生的针对德国犹太人口的“水晶之夜”大屠杀。我们在上一季中做过一集关于它的节目。我认为那场暴力的残酷性，以及希特勒个人负有责任、是他下令的暴力，我不知在某种程度上，他因为没有发动战争而感到的挫败感，
his obsession with- He's like a kind of spoiled, very violent toddler. Yeah. I mean, that's the impression you get with this. Lashing out, exactly. On the second night of Kristallnacht, he summons a closed meeting of German newspaper editors and he says to them, I'm sick of all this stuff about peace, world peace, peace propaganda, peace is the most important thing.
他对……的执念。他就像一个被宠坏的、极度暴力的幼儿。是的。我的意思是，你对这事的印象就是这样。大发雷霆，完全如此。在水晶之夜的第二个晚上，他召集了一场德国报纸编辑的闭门会议，他对他们说，我受够了所有关于和平、世界和平、和平宣传的事情，和平是最重要的事情。
And he said, it isn't the most important thing. You know, we need war. We should arrange things, he says. So, quote, the inner voice of the people itself slowly begins to cry out for the use of force. And from this point, he is already thinking about the next conquest. This is the thing with Hitler. He just cannot, he's addicted. He's like a drug addict needing his next hit.
他说，和平并不是最重要的。你知道的，我们需要战争。他说，我们应该做出安排。所以，引述原话，让人民内心的声音自己慢慢开始呼唤武力。从这一点开始，他已经在考虑下一次征服了。希特勒就是这样。他就是不行，他上瘾了。他就像一个需要下一剂毒品的瘾君子。
Yeah, he needs the next hit. So the next thing he thinks, I'll get the rest of Czechoslovakia. He wants a port called Memel, which was a Baltic German seaport that's now basically been swallowed up by Lithuania. But he's also now for the first time thinking about another target. And this would be his biggest target yet. And this would be Poland. Right, Dominic, thank you.
是的，他需要下一剂。所以他接下来想的是，我要占领剩下的捷克斯洛伐克。他想要一个叫做梅梅尔的港口，那是一个波罗的海德国海港，现在基本上已经被立陶宛吞并了。但这也是他第一次开始考虑另一个目标。这将是他迄今为止最大的目标。这就是波兰。好的，多米尼克，谢谢你。
Very somber, brilliant account. And we will be telling the terrible story of the build up to Hitler's war on Poland, its course and its aftermath next week. And members of the Rest is History Club will get all three episodes of that story on Monday. And if you're not a member of that club, but you would like to get those episodes on Monday, then you can sign up at therestishistory.com. But either way, we will be back with the Nazi war on Poland on Monday. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. As promised, here's a clip from the Rest is Politics US mini series.
非常凝重、精彩的讲述。下周我们将讲述希特勒对波兰战争酝酿过程中的可怕故事、其进程以及随后的影响。历史之余俱乐部的成员将在周一获得该故事的所有三集内容。如果你还不是该俱乐部的成员，但又想在周一获得这些节目，你可以在 therestishistory.com 注册。但无论如何，我们将在周一带着纳粹对波兰的战争回归。再见。再见。如承诺的那样，这里是《政治之余：美国》迷你剧的片段。
Trump is naturally a conspiracy theorist fueler. He will fuel the fire of any conspiracy theory because he's always seen himself as an outsider and he wants to foment the people from the outside to attack the people from the inside. So he's developing these ideas that he eventually uses in January, on the 6th of January. And the ideas are there's misinformation out there, there's lies out there, let's use these lies as fodder to attack the people on the inside. He's doing it with COVID.
特朗普天生就是一个阴谋论的助长者。他会火上浇油地煽动任何阴谋论，因为他一直把自己视为局外人，他想煽动局外的人去攻击局内的人。所以他正在形成这些他最终在1月6日使用的想法。这些想法就是外面有虚假信息，外面有谎言，让我们把这些谎言作为攻击局内人的素材。他在新冠疫情上也这么做。
I think hydroxychloroquine works. You may remember this. I took hydroxychloroquine. Mr. President, you took hydroxychloroquine? Yeah. Yeah, I'm on it. I took it. And this is the beginnings.
我认为羟氯喹有效。你可能还记得这个。我服用了羟氯喹。总统先生，你服用了羟氯喹？是的。是的，我在吃。我吃了。这就是开端。
This is the kernels of what's about to come. And it all starts with COVID. And it leads up to this insurrection, or as the president says, a very peaceful group of tourists descending upon the Capitol building. If you want to hear the rest of the show, go and search the rest is politics US, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是即将发生的事情的萌芽。这一切都始于新冠肺炎。并导致了这场暴动，或者正如总统所说，是一群非常和平的游客来到国会大厦。如果你想收听节目的其余部分，请在你的播客平台上搜索《政治之余：美国》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。